the head of the fbi says there's a lot
more to come from the investigation of
the assault on the capitol and he
expects maybe more serious charges
against people involved in that january
6
attack the house judiciary committee
questioned director christopher wray
about intelligence failures before
january 6.
chris van cleave is on capitol hill for
us chris good morning to you
a lot of people curious to know whether
the director's testimony mentioned
former president trump
well good morning you know the week
started with a major bipartisan senate
report looking at what went wrong on
january 6th but
that report didn't talk about the role
of the former president
the fbi director during hours of
testimony and questioning yesterday
indicated well it really didn't
definitively indicate whether or not his
agency was looking at it but he
certainly didn't roll it out
[Applause]
more than five months after a mob
crashed its way into the capitol
fbi director christopher wray wouldn't
say whether his agency is probing if
president trump
provoked it i'm not aware of any
investigation that specifically goes to
that but we have hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of investigations related
to january 6.
ray acknowledged almost none of the
estimated 500 people now
arrested for their roles in the riot had
been on the fbi's radar
did the fbi simply miss the evidence or
did it see the evidence and fail to
piece it together
you can be darn sure that we are going
to be looking hard
at how we can do better how we can do
more how we can do things differently
including stepped up scrutiny of white
supremacists who rey
said are now the deadliest domestic
threat we have elevated racially
motivated violent extremism
at our highest threat priority level
that's commensurate with isis and
following high-profile cyber hacks that
fueled a frenzy at the pump and
threatened the u.s meat supply
ray said the fbi is investigating about
a hundred different ransomware variants
the cyber threat is increasing almost
exponentially
amid new revelations that jbs the
world's largest meat processor paid 11
million dollars in ransom
ray cautioned other companies should not
aren't we just inviting
more attacks when you pay off these
thugs
it encourages more of this kind of
activity
instead he said call the fbi revealing
the total ransom paid
already has tripled over the past year
the scale of this is something that i
don't think this country has really ever
seen anything quite like it and it's
going to get much worse
race says a lot of these ransomware
attacks originate in russia
but did not elaborate on how closely
linked they are to the kremlin
that is a topic that is likely to come
up when president biden meets with
president putin
next week anthony chris van cleave at
the capitol thanks chris